the Joe Rogan experience will is the man
behind anatomy of the fighter if you
ever seen any of those videos like
particularly the most famous one was
when Conor McGregor threw that dolly at
the bus with khabib nurmagomedov was on
it and it became a huge part of the
promotion which I thought was weird that
it was this shameful act right that he
did that I mean really awful cut a bunch
of innocent people that were on the bus
but they used it over and over and over
again that was your foot yes a lot of
people didn't even know including me no
one did
you know I was telling a friend other
day what's funny no one has ever heard
this but when it happened a show could
be at the back of the bus because he was
had a smile on his face
and I showed him and everybody else on
the bus that I actually caught kind of
doing it because they didn't really know
it was Connor right so my memory could
be looked at the footage I was holding
the camera and he was like brother you
could get paid from this it's like
groans this is worth $100,000 he looked
at his manager ollie a shout-out to javi
and he was like get just get him give
him some money he deserves this and then
I gave it to the UFC to use for embed it
and I thought it was that was just sit
and they promoted the fight with it I
was like damn I should have just leaned
my head to the right and got hit by two
dollies so I not have to be doing it you
know
GoFundMe isn't [ __ ] well what he should
have done is asked for money for it that
video footage was it turned out it was
very valuable because it set up the
fight which also set up the post fight
brawl I mean there was there was so much
that was involved in him throwing that
dolly and you caught that video and they
played that [ __ ] over and over and over
I was actually kind of shocked that they
did that because at the time we like
woke I might go to jail like that was
that was like legitimate assault
they used it the next day I was like
damn I WI means when I saw them like
when I saw it on Fox News and CNN I was
just like that's my footage yeah you
know because you know when you building
us like a channel or a series like that
you think oh this is my moment every
everybody has a moment yeah and
unfortunately the UFC promoted it shout
out to them because they've been nothing
but good to me I
can't say anything I still wish I would
have got something from you should've
got something from pull this my god
just pull just get it up there right
there right there
[Applause]